This episode of DNews is brought to you by
Canon PIXMA Pro professional inkjet printers:
Exactly as you envisioned.
There is way too much UV light in the universe.
So stock up on some SPF 50 and we’re good
right?
Well, not if you’re an astronomer.
Hey there fellow enlightenment sources, Julian
here for DNews.
Right now in the world of astronomy there’s
something of a sticky wicket; Astronomers
have observed five times more Ultraviolet
light than they can account for.
That’s not a minor miscalculation, that
means something is really wrong with our model
of the universe.
UV light is detected because it strips hydrogen
atoms of their electrons, ionizing them.
By taking the amount of ionized gas we can
find, we can get a pretty good idea of how
much UV light is whipping around through space.
So far, so good.
But obviously that UV light has to come from
somewhere.
Obviously stars like our Sun give off UV light
as part of the electromagnetic spectrum they
emit.
Quasars are the superbright regions surrounding
supermassive black holes at the center of
galaxies and they’re getting compressed
and heated so much they’re an enormous source
of UV light.
But when astronomers tally the numbers from
stars and quasars and compare it to the amount
of ionized gas they’ve observed, they come
up short.
Unacceptably short.
It’s like when your mom asks for change
from that 5 she gave you for candy and you
act like there was none.
So where could all this extra light be coming
from?
One suggestion is Dark Matter.
“Aha!”
I hear you say, because you’re a critical
thinker and I love that about you.
“Dark matter, which is still an unproven
hypothesis,” you continue, “should not
absorb or emit electromagnetic radiation.
That’s why it’s called ‘Dark’ matter!”
Wow you’re smart.
And you’re right, so blaming the discrepancy
on Dark Matter looks a lot like grasping at
straws.
But there’s a chance it’s the culprit.
The best hypotheses to explain dark matter
are Weakly Interacting Massive Particles,
or WIMPs.
This is what passes as a joke in the science
world.
Some proposed variations of WIMPs could decay
and release ultraviolet photons.
And since Dark matter accounts for over 80%
of the mass in the universe, that could be
enough to make up the difference.
And if that’s what’s really happening,
this accounting error could lead to direct
proof Dark matter exists and exactly what
it is.
Of course if that’s not what’s happening,
we’re going to have to rethink our model
of the universe a bit.
The UV light conundrum is a great example
of science in action.
To quote Isaac Asimov, “The most exciting
phrase to hear in science, the one that heralds
new discoveries, is not 'Eureka!' but 'That's
funny...'
Obviously you can’t just take a picture
of Dark Matter, but for everything you can
see you can capture it with a Canon.
And when you want to print your glorious proof
of a moment in time, Canon’s got you there
too.
With their PIXMA Pro Professional inkjet printers,
you can expect a level of quality and accuracy
that keeps each print true to your unique
vision.
All backed by Canon's commitment to provide
professionals with fast, high quality service
you can depend on.
For more info on Dark Matter and what it means
for Sci Fi, Anthony in his rare beardless
form has a video on that here.
Can you think of other times small mistakes
lead to scientific revolutions?
Let us know in the comments, be sure to subscribe,
and keep tuning to DNews for more addictive
knowledge.